je vous annonçais dans les titres de
cette édition que nous allions retrouver
dans la deuxième partie de notre journal
pierre tchernia et gilberte goscinny à
propos de l'exposition qui est organisée
au premier étage de la tour eiffel en
hommage à rené goscinny qui disparu il
ya huit ans de cela
alors nous avons demandé à claude crespo
et jean vila de parcourir cette
exposition illustrée par des montages
vidéos et de nous faire rire avec
goscinny qui allait toujours le sourire
aux lèvres la physionomie
c'est l'art de décrypter la personnalité
au travers des traits physiques
bien malin qui pourrait le faire pour
goscinny tenté complexe le personnage et
des indices des scellés çà et là peuvent
éclairer d'abord rené à une enfance très
difficile je suis le cadet d'une famille
de deux enfants jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans
j'ignorais qu'il lui quelque chose entre
le coût et le croupion du poulet le père
était alcoolique et battait mère quand
nous accrochions jupe de mer au placard
et très vite j'ai senti que par le rire
le rire était une défense j'étais
heureux quand je faisais rire ou yaya
ailleurs il ya cet argument là pour
l'humour
comment canaliser cette angoisse
existentielle en touchant à tous et
d'abord au dessin
voici ses deux seules oeuvres elles ne
le satisfaisait pas il préférait écrire
et en collaboration avec d'autres
pinceau naquirent le petit nicolas lucky
luke et bien sûr astérix et obélix
ce couple monstrueux lui est né il ya 15
ans dans pilote
et c'est une autre facette de goscinny
journalistes et rédacteurs un réacteur
qui recrutent avec des méthodes tout
personnel ici al l'inutile
superordinateurs
hal a été acheté par goscinny pour pour
pilotes comme collaborateur et al sert à
quoi sans pilote dans pilote il sert à
tout tout ce que l'on veut il peut être
scénariste dessinateur comptable
d'ailleurs il s'en sort très mal pour
tout comme ça c'est parfait comme son
épouse goscinny a su à la loupe
observez les us et coutumes de son temps
c'est le joinville le seul simon du 20e
siècle
deux secondes de respect s'il vous plaît
de ce bureau sont sortis 160 millions
d'albums d'astérix rené goscinny à noter
les initiales hergé cela ne vous
rappelle rien
ne tapez qu'avec deux doigts mais en
amitié il donnait ses deux mains ti goy
signé est une catastrophe
et bien ce soir là la bouée du steamboat
junior de keaton quand il jette la bouée
pour sauver quelqu'un la boe cool et
goscinny amis c'était quoi
ah c'était formidable parce que c'était
un homme que j'ai toujours vu comme ça
toujours sur ya toujours gai pas
d'humour
c'était le mourre dessin animé
télévision cinéma sur des domaines qui
marqua de son flow mais où donc
allait-il chercher tout ça gd ciel je
dois créer quelque chose je vais
chercher du lait je la trouve
immédiatement je vais crier nous allons
à la plage
bonne baignade me suis aussi et merci
oui gilles van kote